[Music]
meanwhile the big story at the movies
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 which
already makes 17 million dollars just
when I debuted last night first day on
Thursday yeah that's a lot of money so
in honor well here the reasons why we
love it star Chris Pratt okay he's right
here
well who doesn't appreciate a hot guy
flexing getting his Pitt sweat blown dry
and I mean that wink this shirtless shot
he can sign autographs without looking
he can rap about a snack is there
anything Chris Pratt can't do he even
made a mixtape of love songs for his
wife Anna hey girl I'm so in love with
you and I wish I wish she reacted that
way she was kind of looking at me and I
could tell right away big Mis big miss
for me
it's the wrong tempo what do you like
what do you like I need some I need some
EDM notice getting
we could watch him chair dancing all day
now you know we're all so obsessed with
how much chris loves his family yep he
has the cool dad teaching his son Jack
how to tie his own tie Chris definitely
has a soft side he just signed language
this message apologizing to people who
are hearing-impaired for a previous post
where he asked to get rid of subtitles
he says he realized the request was
insensitive chris has been visiting
children's hospitals while he's been on
tour promoting guardians of the galaxy
volume 2 and talked about inspiring the
37 year old revealed he got turned down
for the role of Superman back in 2005
but this is how he sees it the nose that
you get today might mean an even more
powerful yes in the future do you know
what I mean I do I did
[Applause]
[Music]
you